pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
google cherche cherche je cherche je dis
ça suffit ça suffit
[Musique]
et
pascal est commissaire à la brigade des
stups depuis des semaines son équipe
surveille d'importants trafiquants de
drogue
le renseignement est bon josé un
inspecteur a infiltré le réseau
le groupe espère enfin aboutir
aujourd'hui les dealers disent avoir un
kilo d'héroïne à vendre en une seule
fois une quantité exceptionnelle
il ya dans une dose moins d'un dixième
de gramme l'argent contenu dans cette
enveloppe va servir acheté la drogue ou
tout au moins à le laisser croire sont
des fonds qui nous sont officiellement
fournir notre direction kabyle pour fait
police était plus sage entraîneur là
combien là il ya 300 mille francs aux
vestes à 20 7 me pour comptait pas on
sait qu'on fait
[Musique]
diverses importances bas celle des
dragons c'est le détonateur c'est le
détonateur faire briller ses lacets
crédibiliser le fait qu'on soit
concevoir un acheteur de comme si on se
présente comme un acheteur de camon
naissance et tout frais payés donc un
véritable acteur j'ai payé donc à ce
moment là l'argent c'est le messie voyez
pas l'argent c'est plus difficile la
sécurité de josé qui doit aller au
contact avec le dealer est assurée par
une quinzaine d'inspecteurs
les policiers appellent cela un coût
d'achat une opération parfaitement
légale particulièrement périlleuse c'est
toujours des opérations dangereuses tout
simplement parce que par définition le
fonctionnaire lui il sait qu'il est
entouré mais le malfaiteur qui va lui
vendre ne le sait pas et on est quand
même dans un système où on peut pour un
million de centimes ou 20 millions de
centimes
prendre un coup de couteau ou un coup de
revolver donc cette opération qu'on
considère toujours comme dangereuse et
qu on entoure du maximum de sécurité
c'est pour ça que je fais ça suit
toujours de très près ce genre
d'opération
11h40 le départ
pour impressionner le vendeur pour être
crédible la brigade des stups a tout
prévu
l'argent est déposé dans une voiture
étrangère spécialement acheté par le
service pour ce genre d'opération si j'y
vois ça marchait j'ai eu la semaine
dernière
alors comment ça va se passer
mais rendez vous avec le club vendeur
dans un café du côté de l'opéra et puis
la presse avec les modalités de la
transaction
qu'est ce que ça veut dire rivalité de
la transaction mais les conditions de la
transaction
moi ça va la remise en marche
si l'argent de la 4g du cos pour de
l'argent maintenant
l'argentin
faire sortir la marchandise
et dès que la marchandise est sorti aux
collègues ça c'est pas grand monde et
plus particulièrement tendu maintenant
oui
l'ancien que la pratique
le véhicule est stationné à quelques
centaines de mètres du lieu de rendez
vous tout autour les policiers se
mettent en place
surveille il est 12h15
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est reçu 76 2 4 vous n'avez reçu
l'objectif est sur place à vous faites
velours
après quelques minutes passées dans un
café josé regagne le véhicule premier
contretemps
le vendeur est venu accompagné la
discussion s'engage entre les trois
hommes
il est 13 heures les négociations vont
durer plusieurs heures
plusieurs heures pendant lesquelles
personne ne sait ce qu'il se dit à
l'intérieur de la voiture
peu après 16 heures les trois hommes
sortent enfin
josé à la sacoche à la main il a donc
montré les trois cent mille francs il
remet l'argent sécurité dans la voiture
les vendeurs sont pris en filature par
les policiers
josé peut alors faire son rapport
[Applaudissements]
sont tombés d'accord sur une quantité
qui a priori sera d'un kilo et demi
d'héroïne
cette marchandise est pour l'instant
cacher at il dit dans une voiture
quelque part dieu que nous ignorons se
seraient dissimulés dans des bidons
d'huile
un nouveau rendez vous a été convenu à
18h30 entre josé les deux vendeurs ils
doivent revenir avec la drogue
la filature permet de voir les deux
hommes se séparer le premier est suivie
jusqu'à cet hôtel situé à quelques
centaines de mètres de l'opéra en jargon
policier
il est logé l'autre réussi à semer les
inspecteurs dans la foule les policiers
l'imaginent parti récupérer l'héroïne il
est 17h à l'hôtel
commence alors une plante dans une salle
derrière la réception à 18 heures
l'homme organes l'hôtel monte dans sa
chambre mais ces reçus alors je dis
méfiance pour ceux qui sont dans la rue
himat
pour les policiers la drogue est
maintenant dans ses murs à 18h25
les deux vendeurs parts livrer la drogue
les policiers décident d'intervenir
hop
bon vous annoncez conférer un ouais
c'est bon orateur seul individu
interpellé interpellé vous trouvez
descente on est bien portants doigt sur
les policiers pensent trouver la drogue
sur l'homme à l'imperméable bleu mais il
n'a rien sur lui les deux suspects ne
disent pas un mot ne proteste pas les
inspecteurs n'ont pourtant pas donné les
raisons de l'interpellation
non il voyage beaucoup le monsieur très
bien sa forme la jeunesse
alors votre passeport
examinons ce rap c'est quoi nous à une
profession et votre profession monsieur
ces commerçants juste pour être sûr
après cette première fouille
infructueuse les inspecteurs monde
cherchait dans la chambre pour éviter
toute protestation
la perquisition ne peut se faire qu'en
présence de l'individu interpellé
d'accord à tout ça sur le paletot revers
la chambre est mis sens dessus dessous
pendant 30 minutes les policiers ne
trouve rien rien jusqu'à ce qu'ils
cherchent
sur le palier
bah ouais c'est ressemble à rien c'est
ça c'est ça se voit je descends jean
michel c'est bon c'est quoi ça
c'est pas forcément son plaisir à
regarder ce y en a d'autres on va
regarder mais apparemment c'est vrai de
l'héroïne marrant bon bah c'est ça
l'héroïne marron et de l'héroïne baron
héroïne marron par contre bon vivre la
cram oui à temps c'est peut-être
ça vous ça non voilà c'est dans une
bouteille de une crème une crème
quelconque sais pas c'est pas un produit
un produit le français
on a à l'intérieur alors une première
bonbonnes le site contient environ une
vingtaine de grammes d'héroïne marron et
un deuxième un deuxième bouddha qui à vu
d'oeil contient environ 500 g 500
grammes d'héroïne marbre à vue d'oeil un
saut un kilo et demi un kilo et demi au
total c'est une opération une opération
parfaitement réussie avec un
conditionnement et un mode de transport
quand même sort de l'ordinaire
les deux hommes interpellés ne savent
pas encore comment les policiers sont
remontés jusqu'à eux
il nie toujours être les propriétaires
de la drogue
l'un des deux refuse maintenant de
parler en français
je sais qu'une chose heroes nom de pie
pour comme gerry barr définitif ici dit
non à maastricht me dis vraiment things
you gonna go my du rocket
[Musique]
au gd comme l'observatoire géopolitique
des drogues
créé il y a trois ans ici on répertorie
tout ce qui se passe dans le monde en
matière de stupéfiants spécialiste
français de la drogue
alain labrousse et à laval on dirige cet
organisme indépendant
nous leur avons demandé ce que
représente une telle saisie d'héroïne
si on compare aux prises de l'an passé 1
kg sur 3 127 kilos d'héroïne
c'est donc à la fois peu et pas mal
simplement on estime que
l'héroïne qui rentrent en france est
largement supérieur que peut-être on est
autour de entre sac et 15% de saisies un
suivant les périodes bon donc c'est
finalement assez peu alors que
faudrait-il faire il faudrait
s'intéresser peut-être davantage à la
production et surtout aux complicités
dont elle bénéficie si on regarde
l'héroïne donc parlons en france qui est
là la drogue qui causent tous les
problèmes 75% sont produits dans le
croissant d'or c'est à dire par le
pakistan et l'afghanistan
or au pakistan on s'aperçoit que les
barons de l'héroïne se situe au plus
haut poste du gouvernement que les
services secrets de l'armée sont
eux-mêmes investi dans le trafic on ne
note pas de la part des puissances
occidentales et de la france et ce qui
nous concerne une action diplomatique
vigoureuse vis-à-vis des gouvernements
de ces pays et pourquoi
et bien parce que nous avons des
intérêts économiques incontestable dans
ces pays dans le cas du pakistan par
exemple ou leur vendant des armes et
qu'on sait même que une partie de ces
armes peut être payés avec l'argent de
l'héroïne
donc là les intérêts économiques
stratégiques de nos pays prime sur la
lutte où la guerre la drogue
20h30 36 quai des orfèvres
les deux hommes interpellés sont de
nationalité rwandaise en situation
régulière en france ils sont
officiellement arrivé il ya un mois avec
un visa de touriste
dans ces sachets il y a de quoi
confectionner entre quatre et cinq mille
doses chaque dose lait vendu 800 francs
au détail une fois coupée cette drogue
aurait donc rapporter plus de 3 millions
de francs c'est moi qui se consomme
comment les revenus vie qu'on fume et
puis on se laisse lire matière comme ça
il faut la transformer un nom comme ça
enfin celle avec la pureté s'est rappelé
que je pense qu'ils en gros comme ça des
métis ponctionner l'excès et bonnes
habitudes en voilà devrait alors quand
sa chance raul7 this led blanches fils à
la thaïlandaise c'est le truc comme ça
ça soit vraiment non cela c'est un
accord qui vient de dire au pakistan
c'est une immense majorité la date aux
alentours de 21h le premier
interrogatoire
les deux hommes nient encore ils ne
comprennent toujours pas comment les
policiers sont remontés jusqu'à eux
mais ouais j'attendis paris à la télé
johnny damon a jamais jaurès il
proposait déjà mais c'est d'en vendre
non bien sûr aussi sûr que moi je suis
sur lequel les devants tôt - quoi est ce
que toi tu mens ou est ce que moi je
m'en fous je te dis que tu business dans
la drogue
je mange le malfaisant réveillon 21h15
l'explication la présentation à josé
policiers faux acheteurs meurtri du
bonus intéressants et que tu vois déjà
pour les tiroirs l'homme qui a de suite
qu'est ce tu sais bien que c'est marqué
dessus pour commencer ce qui renforce et
là c'est sa cravate salma il fait
toujours mal à le fuir
bien malin c'est monsieur
le policier
tu comprends un peu ma page
on comprend qu'on prend bien soin adapté
à la clio iv à nice un peu à elle avec m
moi je suis fou et comprend ce jeu
d'expliquer la seconde
oui ça me regarde leur médecin regarde
le problème c'est que dans la terre on
est associés tous les deux hélas hélas
hélas au niveau de la justice ont
d'associer tous les deux mais si on tond
cac est intéressant ou alors tu
t'écoutes puisque tu veux comprendre
devra comprendre c'est pas grave il ya
ce que je vais dire ce que j'ai entendu
ce que tu m'as dit est ce que mes
collègues ont vu d'accord si l'on est
bien c'est très bien d'accord mais les
bases ne sont plus celles maintenant tu
vois quoi les bases sont plus celles qui
connaît la situation maintenant nos
radios de la patinoire qui monte c'est
waouh c'est moi de faire quoi sinon je
te dis que tu vas rester dans l'anonymat
ou c'est moi qui me rendent deux heures
c'est l'heure du bilan pour les
policiers
voilà l'impression qu'avec des coups
comme ça d'un kilo
plusieurs centaines de grammes vous
lutter efficacement contre le trafic de
drogue oui oui oui mais par contre ce
qui est inquiétant c'est de voir que
que la cam ou rentrer en france par kilo
on en saisit un de temps en temps et
puis on peut se poser la question
combien combien vous en passe sous le
nez au sénat non non scission aussi si
on y réfléchit
bon c'est sûr que c'est démoralisant
mais bon il faut continuer et puis et
puis comme de plus en plus de policiers
maintenant font des affaires de
stupéfiants finira peut-être par arriver
à quelque chose arrive à quoi au moins
je ne dis pas à envoyer complètement le
trafic ccc de l'utopisme et à faire
reculer les trafiquants parce que bon en
france on est quand même un pays où les
trafiquants prennent des lourdes peines
bon ça peut ça peut au moins les
éloigner de france en garde espoir oui
bien sûr
sinon je ferais plus ça
au cours de leur garde à vue les deux
hommes ont tous reconnu tout avoué
d'après les policiers
pour une affaire comme celle-ci ils
seront condamnés à 10 ans de réclusion
en france on estime à 300 mille le
nombre de toxicomanes à l'héroïne
chaque année 500 meurent d'overdose met
à paris depuis deux ans et demi
une nouvelle drogue a fait son
apparition le crack dérivé de la cocaïne
le crack est vendu ici à paris dans le
quartier de stalingrad
la dépendance est immédiate terrible
cette femme cherche à même le sol de
quoi soulager son manque les miettes
tombées lors des précédentes
transactions
ces images ont été filmées avec une
caméra dissimulée dans une manche de
blousons
le crack se fume provoque un flash qui
dure une vingtaine de minutes détruit le
cerveau
[Musique]
les policiers ne peuvent pas infiltré
ces lieux sans se faire remarquer ce
soir-là en planque dans le quartier ils
aperçoivent deux toxicomanes entrer dans
un immeuble
il
[Musique]
sa lâcheté ça où et quand la quille nom
des maîtres qui passe et qui passe et
j'ai cassé le seuil du bassin ainsi le
pas aux dépens de cailloux traque les
français
s'apprête à fumer il y avait là la
bouteille de fanta là il a vu la
médaille de fantômes les deux fentes
artisanale avec une grille un toxicomane
au crack fumé une dizaine de cailloux
par jour mille francs pour ne pas être
en manque pour lutter contre le
développement de la toxicomanie
le syndicat de la magistrature suggère
une politique radicalement différente
cette proposition a été faite lors du
dernier congrès en novembre
nous avons demandé la dépénalisation de
l'usagé des produits stupéfiants
du moment qu lusage a lieu en privé et
dans des conditions qui ne porte pas
atteinte à autrui
pourquoi alors nous avons le sentiment
que nous faisons le constat un peu du
système dans lequel nous sommes nous
sommes nous avons le sentiment que ce
système a fait la preuve de son
inefficacité la politique répressive qui
a été menée n'a fait que dynamiser le
marché de la drogue c'est à dire que
plus on interpelle deux dealers plus on
interpelle aussi d'usagé
plus on fait monter le cours de la
drogue et en faisant monter le cours de
la drogue on dynamise en quelque sorte
le marché de la drogue
tout ça me paraît pas très sérieux si
vous voulez je crois que c'est plutôt
des réflexions d'intellectuels un coupé
un petit peu des réalités dont beaucoup
n'ont peut-être pas vu souvent des
toxicomanes d'ailleurs un et donc je
crois que là on est dans une phase au
contraire ou en europe les pays
eux-mêmes qui ont dépénalisé commence à
le regretter amèrement et font marche
arrière
donc si vous voulez c'est une approche
que je qualifierais de surpoids de
communes de munich oise en quelque sorte
et de défaitiste parce que aussi on peut
raisonner comme ça pour tous les pôles
de la délinquance alors si vous voulez
je crois que c'était là on nous en fait
une question très plus de respect de la
jeunesse parce qu'on ne joue pas si vous
voulez avec la jeunesse on ne joue pas
avec l'avenir d'une jeunesse s'est pas
fait c'est pas admissible de faire des
expériences avec les jeunes cet homme a
été interpellé le 26 novembre dernier
place stalingrad chez lui les
inspecteurs de la brigade des stups ont
découvert 400 grammes de crack la plus
importante saisie jamais réalisée à
paris la plus inquiétante
il y a dans ces sachets de quoi
fabriquer 4500 doses quatre cent
cinquante mille francs à la revente
le crack va-t-il devenir laroque de l'an
2000 va-t-il remplacer l'héroïne au
cours de sa garde à vue cet homme
donnera les noms des principaux
grossistes de la place essentiellement
des antilles et
si on se bat et je compte bien monsieur
nuit après nuit les inspecteurs de la
police judiciaire tente de retrouver les
dealers ce qui alimente les 400 fumeurs
de crack connu pour l'instant la
stalingrad
un petit tour chine
c'est donc le travail ordinaire d'une
brigade des stups
un travail de fourmi dérisoire mais
nécessaire demain il y aura d'autres
vérifications
d'autres arrestations
[Musique]